[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing slytherin house
more specifically we're going to be
discussing the morality
of some of its former members in the
philosopher's stone
hagrid once famously remarked that
there's not a single witch or wizard who
went bad
who wasn't in slytherin however there
are of course a few big issues with
hagrid's blanket statement
the first issue being that the hagrid is
blatantly exaggerating
and generalizing of course there were
bad wizards who came from other houses
the second issue with this statement is
the wording as many people have
interpreted it
as all slytherins will become bad when
what hagrid really meant was
all bad witches and wizards come from
zytherin which is
also not true the fact remains that at
the end of the day
there are witches and wizards who have
come from slytherin that ended up just
fine
or at least had some form of character
arc involving a change in their moral
compass
in today's video we're going to be
taking a look at some of those
characters
number seven phineas black i know what
you're thinking
wasn't phineas black the awful
prejudiced ex-hogwarts headmaster that
everyone hated yes certainly but that
was phineas nigella's black
this is phineas black his son just
because he shared a name and blood with
his father
it didn't mean that he ended up anything
like him in fact
vinnie's black was a source of great
shame for his father why
you might ask well as it turned out
phineas actually believed in local
rights
a belief that got him disowned by his
father and removed from the black family
tree
phineus as it turned out was a genuine
person
number six andromeda tonks andromeda
tonks
born andromeda black of the house of
black was an english witch that married
muggleborn at ted tonks
given that she came from the house of
black a family of pure blood
supremacists
it should come as no surprise that she
was disowned by her family
for her marriage together her and ted
had a daughter
named fedora who we know as a respected
aura and member of the order of the
phoenix
andromeda was certainly no evil witch
number five aristocorn
horus slughorn was an english pure blood
wizard born sometime between 1882
and 1913. when he attended hogwarts as a
boy
he was sorted into southern house and
because he embodied many aspects of
southern house
he embraced it when he was older he even
became head of the house
a role given to one individual
responsible for looking after and
disciplining the students of the house
given slytherin's reputation for
producing dark witches and wizards
this role took someone with a firm hand
and though saigon can seem quite
aloof at times he's incredibly sharp and
even more powerful
with all of that said however the only
thing that starcorn was really guilty of
was being a bit of a social climber that
and wanting to be liked by many
deep down slughorn certainly wasn't a
bad person and the pivotal role that he
played in the battle of hogwarts
should be more than enough for anyone to
forgive his less
favorable traits number four merlin
purportedly the most powerful wizard to
have ever lived
merlin graced the grounds of hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
just a few years after it opened its
doors in 1990 a.d
he was one of the first students there
period and given the close proximity of
his attendance of the school's founding
it's likely that he was taught directly
under salazar's the lyrin's tutelage
however despite being taught unto him
merlin never allowed himself to be
tainted
with salazar's negative perception of
muggles and muggle-borns
in fact merlin was a firm believer that
the muggle and wizarding worlds
should be able to co-exist in harmony he
believed so strongly in his cause that
he founded an organization
in an effort to help alleviate any
complications associated
with the coalescence of the two worlds
in this time period there was a
particularly large amount of conflict
between mughals and wizards the
wizarding world was essentially wide
open
and muckles knew that witches and
wizards walked among them however
rather than embracing them for their
magical abilities muggles were
exceedingly harsh
when it came to dealing with magical
folk they treated them like freaks
like spawn of the devil and hunted them
down in purges called
witch hunts what this tells me about
merlin's character
is that he was particularly pure of
heart as he was able to take the moral
high ground
and still consider the greater good of
the world when his own people were being
persecuted
number three regulus black regulus black
aka rab aka the younger brother of
sirius black
was a pure blood wizard born into the
house of black in 1972
he was sorted into slytherin and true to
the path of so many others before him
ended up joining voldemort's death
eaters however
very much unlike most others that had
become death eaters
regulus eventually defected after
learning of what voldemort wanted to do
to achieve power he notably learned of
voldemort's horcruxes
and even attempted to destroy salazar's
lyrin's locket
while regulus is still a character with
a certain degree of moral ambiguity
his actions later in life suggest that
he unlike many other dark wizards had a
certain degree of compassion for others
as he aged he left the more selfish and
darker side of himself behind
in pursuit of a more brave selfless
existence
even when it came time to sacrifice
himself regulars expressed
genuine concern for the well-being of
creature and his family
given that regulus was more or less
estranged at this point
it further suggests that he had become a
good man
number two albus potter albus severus
potter
the son of the famed harry potter was
famously named after two of the bravest
men that harry ever knew
albus for albus dumbledore and severus
for severus snape
albus began attending hogwarts in 2017
and shortly after arriving the school
was sorted into slytherin house
alongside scorpius malfoy what's
interesting about albus's initial
sorting
however is that he never wanted to be in
southern at all
in fact he was so against being sorted
into the house
that it was all he could think about
leading up to the sorting
ironically this likely resulted in his
placement there
as when the sorting hat was analyzing
his mind all it could see was
slytherin fluttering slytherin albus
struggled during his initial time at the
school
mainly because he had difficulty with
the pressure placed on him
as a result of his father's legacy he
was quiet
mostly kept to himself and developed a
dry sense of humor in response to the
pressure
bullying placed on him from his peers
but in spite of the pressure placed on
albus and the bullying he received
he never succumbed to at all which
speaks volumes to his character
number one snape sephora snape born
january 9th
1960 to a muggle father and witch mother
grew up on a street called spinner's end
in the town of coke worth
the start of snape's life was rough and
it didn't get much better for him when
he began attending hogwarts
for you see snape who had developed
feelings for a young girl by the name of
lily evans
ended up being sorted into an entirely
different house than her
placing a divide between the young pair
right to the beginning of their studies
snape's time at hogwarts was rough he
was bullied for being different
for being weird and was particularly
targeted by the marauders which included
harry's father
james in response to this bullying snape
went dark
and eventually joined voldemort's death
eaters there was a time when
certainly snape was a bad egg but upon
hearing of simple trolone's prophecy
and the danger that it would place lily
evans in snape had a change of heart
and changed allegiances however despite
changing sides
snape acted successfully as a double
agent with voldemort believing that
snape was still loyal to him
in the end of harry potter just after
his death his name's character arc is
completed
and his true motivations are finally
revealed to harry snape
who always seemed so evil so awful
actually had a lot of good in him and
that's it for this video
which slytherins do you think deserved
to be on this list
let me know in the comment section below
if you enjoy the content please like the
video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
you're a wizard howry
you